recording this one two armed men in
plain clothes
one of them puts on a police cat
pedestrians are confused as undercover
officers
surround a man on the ground
from the voices of those filming this
scene we know the man has already been
shot
twice he's either dead or dying
according to witnesses moments earlier
he'd been stabbing people
in the street but undercover officers
were quick to the scene
it's not clear why but the new arrivals
keep their distance
then the mets armed response team arrive
they approach with caution
witnesses say the man on the ground was
wearing what could have been
an explosive vest
now there's a sudden turn of events as
police rapidly urge pedestrians to clear
the
area
very quickly i see people
screaming and running down the high
street and
behind those people was a guy who was of
like i'm sure was the best that he was
running same time
and the police were after him with a gun
and they were telling him stop that
which he did not stop
and all i've seen that had to shock him
three times i just saw a like a sort of
fight scuffle
but that's kind of normal around here so
just ignored it
kept my head down and then uh just saw
people pushing
other people against uh rules of around
little
and then i heard like a shout and then
everyone ran off
and uh one guy laying on the floor and
definite blood
around him we now know why
officers reacted so quickly the attacker
was under surveillance at the very
moment he struck
one eyewitness filming turns back up the
high street
and here pedestrians tend to those
wounded by the stabbings
someone filming from a balcony captures
the full horror of what's happened
this is not a high profile target area
just an ordinary high street
no famous landmarks but the stabbings
here bear resemblance to the london
bridge attack of a little over two
months ago where two people were killed
by someone recently released from prison
and what it seems is that even someone
being followed
under surveillance they can if they're
determined enough
bring terror to the uk jason farrell sky
news